by travelpod
and those are our wii u nominees for
game of the year on gamespot com okay
good year for the wii u it turns out
2014 what's your great games last year I
just picked one up last week turns head
has a bunch of great games for it who
knew and the interesting discussion here
in relation to scores first of all I
want to bring up gamespot's first ten in
a number of years at Bayonetta 2 Chris
you enjoyed this bad boy right I've only
scratched the surface with Bayonetta 2
but it's entirely based on mark Waltons
review I mean gamespot's given I think
eight tens in its entire 18-year history
so you know the guard changes but the
standard stay the same and for a game to
earn a 10 on gamespot it has to be
phenomenal in just an essential part of
the collection for that console that
system that it's on and bayonetta is you
know by all accounts just an immaculate
action game just the pacing of the the
action and the systems and the combat
mechanics and how they all flow together
so seamlessly just make it an incredible
accomplishment and it's a beautiful
experience has got like these incredible
set pieces that are so ornate and to see
it happen for walkers yeah to see this
running on the Wii U as well as it does
it's pretty crazy because it's got a
reputation among you know like people
like to argue assistant Moore's like do
we use underpowered you'd be
hard-pressed to say that watching this
game in action and this isn't the kind
of game that you typically get on with
you and this is a much more adult game
in some ways I mean it doesn't have a
ridiculous amount of blood or anything
like that but much more adult than most
of the nominee it has a lot more butts
than Mari yeah I'm Donkey Kong tropical
freeze another nominee and one which
that's just all but doc econ it's a game
that a lot of vigilant gamespot users
would be like wait a second back in
February you guys gave this is 6 out of
10 what's it dealing on top five games
of the year and most interesting where
you came from the same reviewer that
gave Bayonetta yes interest yeah Mark
Watson of course for UK office so what
is it about DK and why we why do we have
a game they got six at a time in our
lives I mean that's the thing that the
same way that some people would give
they
to attend the that same person isn't
here in this room like I wouldn't
necessarily score that the same way in
Donkey Kong tropical freeze is a game
that for a lot of us is a lot more
beloved it is a game that was for some
of us nines and tens yeah and i think
you know his biggest problem mark walton
stemmed from the fact that he'd a hard
time like simply flowing through the
levels as it were and and that sort of
prevented him from making progress or
having a lot of fun but this game is
hard yeah it looks you know childish but
it is very very hard but it's got some
really ingenious level design both from
an artistic and like you know actual
like being a functional level and it's
for me it's one of my favorite games of
the year from there on the wii u I mean
it's for it to get a sixth was it was
very shocking me personally and you're
not the only one there are a lot of
voices clamoring for tropical freeze in
the discussion and I think these
discussions are what makes games box
Game of the Year awards so special is
because while a review you know we we
always stand by our reviews and they
always you know reflect the the opinion
of the reviewer and they've backed it up
well we are a collection of individuals
as well and so coming together to sort
of discuss these games and hash out
which ones we we think the ones it rise
to the top are are the best ones yeah
and I'm there's so many great games came
out this year but we're also going to
get quite a lot of repetition and we
have our repair our first repeat visitor
of the year coming up in the wii u
category shovel nights back and the same
things that made it wonderful on the 3ds
also make it wonderful on on wii u it's
graphically a very similar experience
all the way you you don't have the same
strip has functionality of course but it
still just such an amazing platforming
game in addition to as Peter mentioned
the different gameplay mechanics that
borrow from not just other old-school
platformers but modern games like Dark
Souls and it makes really well too and
our second repeat visitor of the day
another one we just had from the 3ds is
super smash bros but fair to say it's a
it's a fairly different experience on
the Wii U the super smash brothers only
you not only adds a lot of functionality
that we didn't get on the 3ds version
it's a game that is much friendlier on
the week on the TV screen of course you
have a lot more screen real estate you
have a lot more people you can play with
I mean they up the number of
28 if you want a really really insane
experience but this is a game that you
know traditionally we sit around we play
couch co-op and you can punch someone in
the arm if they're getting the better of
you in and just be that kind of physical
wheel game already four fantastic
contenders there and our nominees for
Best Wii U game of the year and the last
one it wouldn't be a year with a
nintendo console would add at least one
mario game making it in there and mario
kart 8 is a game that's been popular
throughout the office absolutely i mean
there's a lot of this game and Smash
Brothers was sort of one of the heated
ones I mean they were both gonna you
know make it onto the list but then when
we're talking when we were sort of
debating their merits I think people
whose like my go-to like end of the day
in the office game is smash brothers
rule ours is well I'd like the in the UK
it's mario kart 8 here we had a little
bit smash like but then we have people
defecting on other side I mean this is
just this you know it's it's that same
kind of formula that works has worked so
well over the years but i think the wii
u version thrives in a way that previous
mario kart I mean it just keep they keep
setting the bar higher and higher and
Nintendo games are always going to be
near the top of the nominee list for a
nintendo console for the wii u game of
the year because they make such fun
friendly experiences that even maybe if
you're not a cart racing van or a mario
kart fan this is an easy game to jump
into and learn how to play the same with
smash brothers even if you're not a
fighting game fan it's a quick easy to
pick up and play game yeah five a strong
nominees there for best wii u game of
the year and you can find it who wins
gamespot's best wii u game of the year
2014 in just a couple of days on
december 13th so make sure you come